this talk is gonna hit the two trillion
valuation they were trading at that
magical two trillion dollar level
they've reached the two trillion two
point one trillion two trillion dollar
valuation two trillion dollar IPO if
you've come across the Aramco IPO story
you're going to have heard the figure 2
trillion bandied about headline number
is stunning MBS has long wanted this
goal the West had told him it was
unreasonable and now he's achieved it a
billion dollar startup is called a
unicorn so what do you call a company
that's worth two thousand times that
it'd probably help at this point to
quantify how much two trillion really is
two trillion dollars is more than most
countries annual GDP if a Ramco were a
country it would actually be in the top
ten of global economies it's listing
cause Saudi Arabia's market size to jump
three hundred and seventy percent and
clinched seventh position in the global
rankings so how did Saudis millennial
prints achieve this gigantic valuation
and how did a ram Co get so big in the
first place or vast trackless desert
Saudi Aramco actually started as an
American company roadless almost unknown
unmapped in 1933 a concession agreement
was signed between Saudi Arabia and the
Standard Oil Company of California which
is now Chevron to allow the Americans to
start prospecting California Arabian
Standard Oil was born
but it wasn't until 1938 in Derron that
they actually found enough oil to drill
in commercial quantities at demand well
number seven which became known as
prosperity while in 1949 crude oil
production had hit 500,000 barrels per
day and the scale of the kingdom's
potential riches was becoming apparent
oil prices spiked at the peak of the
Arab oil embargo in 1973 with tensions
growing between OPEC countries in the
u.s. the Saudi government acquired 25
percent more of Aramco
increasing its stake to 60% making them
the majority shareholder by 1980 it had
completed its nationalization but the
headquarters remained in Delaware it
wasn't until 88 that operations were
fully moved to the kingdom and it
changed its name once again to the Saudi
Arabian oil company of Saudi Aramco the
nationalization of our uncle was very
different to every other nationalization
to happen not only in the Middle East
but also in Africa and Latin America
that's Bloomberg's chief energy
correspondent Xavier Blass the company
retained a lot of their employees the
only thing that changed was the
ownership but the way to run the company
a very technocratic company where
politics were not welcome we made in the
late 80s under the leadership of its
first Saudi president Ali al-naimi Saudi
Aramco went from just pumping oil to
doing it all it brought up refineries
across North America
and all through Asia to control the
processes involved in converting oil and
gas into the finished product this has
made it the most profitable company in
the world or some aspects of the company
were changing others remain the same
since the nationalization of Saudi
Aramco in the late 70s early 80s the
company was always separated from the
politics of the kingdom it was run by
engineers the most precious thing was
technical capability and the cooverman
led Aramco run the company
the rise of Prince Mohammed bin Salman
changed all of that the crown prince
also known as MBs had a much more
hands-on approach when it came to Aramco
tell us again exactly who this Prince is
his nickname is mr. everything which is
to say that he is basically been put in
control of massive swathes of Saudi
Arabia since Mohammed bin Salman became
the deputy Crown Prince and later the
crown prince it has been a lot more
influence from the royal court and the
royal family but it wasn't until 2016
when NBS announced his vision 2030 that
his plans for Aramco
dual really became apparent of course we
can't not mention the planned IPO of
Saudi Aramco it is a dramatic change by
anyone's look we know whether he
succeeds or not it's something that
we're all waiting see the reaction to
Prince Mohammed announcement in 2016 of
the IPO and the wider program of
economic liberalisation that is known
now as vision 2030 was received through
the war with a lot of enthusiasm it was
a move by Saudi Arabia to try to get
away from oil diversified income
privatized economy make things more
flexible increase employment etc etc
taking a Ramco public was at the heart
of MBS is pushed to revamp Saudis
economy which needs billions of dollars
to develop new industries and fund
ambitious mega projects the biggest
problem from the very beginning of the
IPO was devaluation Prince Mohammed
announced that the company was value at
two trillion dollars it's more than
doubled the valuation of the largest
companies in America and very few
international investors believe that
that number was right Saudi Arabia has
said Saudi Aramco is worth more than two
trillion dollars but does the kingdom
have to settle for less a person
familiar with IPO talk said they place
the figure at less than one trillion
dollars a person the Saudi government
five hundred billion would McKenzie four
hundred billion they became very clear
that the two trillion dollar was not on
a war with international investors so
they decided to take a pause it's the
crown jewel
of the kingdom's economy the most
profitable company in the world but now
thanks to a string of setbacks the most
anticipated IPO ever has seriously been
scaled back a United Nations report says
the crown prince of Saudi Arabia should
be investigated over the murder of
journalist Jamal khashoggi I think this
ought to be a relationship altering
event for the US and Saudi Arabia did
you order the murder of Jamal khashoggi
Buick absolutely not a twin attack at
night with drones on two major Saudi oil
facilities one of them the largest in
the world the attack cut the world's oil
supply by about five percent I would
just point to the fact that the energy
sector as a percentage of the ESPE
weighting is now 4.2 percent it was 16
and a half percent ten years ago this is
a sector left for dead with a string of
weighty news events stacking up the
Saudis and talks of the IPO went quiet
leaving many to question if it'd been
put on hold permanently
[Music]
then in 2019 around the summer Saudi
Arabia got really concerned that the
price of all was gonna drop because of
the slowdown in the global economy the
trade war between the US and China and
they decided to reseller eight the plan
and to try to get the company a game
public by the end of 2019 they were able
to do that but they have to make some
sacrifices final pricing values the
world's profitable company at one point
seven trillion dollars but somewhat
below the Kingdom's original target
listing in Riyadh only the International
part of the IPO which has been long
suggested and isn't clear when that will
happen just not offering as many shares
as originally thought so just one point
five percent of the company is being
offered something uncle went ahead they
did the IPO at one point seven trillion
dollars and they really when I'm put
pressure on every wealthy family into
the kingdom to put money into their
uncle valuation they also pressure the
banks the local banks to lend more money
into the local economy to allow citizens
to buy shares with with borrow money and
in the moment that the company went
public and the day that the trading
started
they also made sure that pension funds
and others in Saudi Arabia where buyers
on the first day so immediately we
caught to 1.8 trillion dollars and then
a couple of days later we hit two
trillion dollars historic day for
company this is the
the biggest listing in the history after
pricing at the high end of the valuation
the IPO raised twenty nine point four
billion dollars beating the record 25
billion raised by Alibaba in New York in
2014 but what does the future look like
for an oil Titan in the age of going
green even Aramco who used to downplay
Peak Oil cited it as a risk in its IPO
prospectus the problem with Peak Oil and
Saudi Aramco is that come 2030 there is
not gonna be incremental demand for oil
and that means that Saudi Aramco cannot
continue growing his production forever
and that means lower revenue in the
future potentially lower prices and that
means also lower profits there is still
a long way to go before the Aramco IPO
can be considered a success its
record-breaking listing cannot hide the
potential challenges that face the
company further down the line it remains
to be seen if this oil Titan can truly
reinvent the country's economy and fund
MBS is ambitious plans for the kingdom
[Music]
you
you